Đúc bỏng sân nghiệp dù lịch đe bán hợp đồng kinh nghi,
môi một công ty cùng hai chăm người với bị công an thành phố hồ chiming hợi tổ về hành tì lừa đạo chấm bạch tại sản.
Vậy thu đoạn của đứng dây này hoạt động thế nào?
Theo cơ quan đều chá, nhóm này sẽ giúp quy trình lừa đạo của một bốn bước,
bước một chuẩn bị và tim kếm bị hại.
Để tạo hình ảnh trưng nghiệp, các công ty thui và phòng quy mô lớn,
lâu thư cơ sở và chất và xây dựng bộ mảnh nhân sự đầy đủ,
từ bàn giám đốc quản lý pháp lý đến Telet sales,
nhân kiên kinh giói và chăm sóc hát hạn.
Nóm khách hàng mà họ nhóm đến chủ yếu là người cao tuổi,
có điều kiện kinh tế, phọc môn muốn tìm kiểm 1 tuy nhập thu đậu.
Bước hai, tiếp cận và thư bánh, sau đó,
nhân viên liên tục gọi điện mời khách tham dự các buổi từ bánh,
hứa tạc qua hoặc trải nghiệp kinh nghiệp miễn viễn viễn viễn để tạo lòng tinh.
Tại các buổi này, họ giới thiệu từ bốn đến sấu gọi hợp đồng kinh nghi,
có giả từ 8 mươi đến 4,5 mươi chỗ đồng.
Đi kèm là hàng loạt kâm kết thấp dẫn,
nhiều lợi nhật có thể tăng gấp bốn lần,
lại xuất tảm đến 1,5 mươi, được rân nghiệp mua lại hợp đồng,
khoảng hỗ trợ sang nhật.
Thập chỉ, nhóm này còn hửa hỗ trợ chuyển nhận các hợp đồng
bị giữa mà khách đăng sở hiếu tại rân nghiệp khác.
Bước bà, ký hợp đồng và thu tiền.
Thì khách hàng đồng ý, nhân viên nhân chống đưa hợp đồng sản sản địa kiếc,
các hợp đồng này có nhiều điều quan bất lợi cho người mua.
Nếu khách không đủ hả năng tài chính,
nhân viên còn hướng dẫn vài tính dụng nân hàng với hạm mất lớn để tiếp tục thình toán.
Đến khi khách muốn thành lý hợp chuyển nhận hợp đồng,
các nhân viên tiếp tục yêu cầu nống thêm nhiều khoảng phi,
nhiều phi tụt tục,
phi chuyển nhật,
phiến nâng cấp gọi dịch vụ,
phi thế trên và các khoảng phi khác.
Sau khi nông tiền, khách lại bị thích phục ký thêm hợp đồng mới,
với lời hướng sẽ sửm hoàn bốn khoảng dịch lợi dịch như cảm kết.
Gưới nhiều vầy, nhiều người tiếp tục dơi vào vòng sảy đồng từ
đống thêm tiền nhưng không thể thu hồi số tiền đã bỏ ra.
Cái gì các xin thì cái hưởng nạn phải hảm,
thì có thể là mọi người hảm lấy làm việc,
sử lý hoặc là tiếp tục,
và đúng các bạn muốn thấy họ đồng.
Tiền tụi về thì,
hả,
chính là phạm,
hướng thích khác nhầm chính là.
Bằng cách này,
phạm xin thái các công ty đã kiế hướng năm gì năm 2020,
chếm đoạn hơn 6% đồng của khách hàng.
Công chỉ tại thành phố Hồ Chí Minh,
công an hả nội cũng vừa hợi tổ 2,5 vụ an,
liên quan 2,5 bệ công ty với thủ trạng tương tự.
Nhà chức khác rất định,
khoảng nơi bệnh in hợp đồng sẽ yếu kỳ nghỉ,
đã được các công ty này kí kết,
khoảng nó lừa đạo khoảng 2,5% đồng.